oh you know I'm kind of excited because
I went to visit mrs. Kim of the Tilton
elbow and with the dual elbow is yoga
elbow is a very big as you know good
question purpose of our audience here is
a very big it's a major one of the major
newspapers in Korea they have a Canadian
you know version or a Vancouver version
magazine Canadian version because most
of the Koreans in wow there's a lot of
Koreans in Toronto but at any rate she
runs a place here and when I was in my
doing my Korean about seven years ago at
that time she did an article in her
newspaper and she was very helpful and
and so now that I started up again I
went to see her to see if there's any
way that we can cooperate with them
whether it be here in Vancouver or
possibly in Korea in some way and the
first thing she had was she had her
editor interviewing so I did an
interview about 20 minutes hundred
percent in Korea so I was very excited
nobody know you were gonna be doing this
no for you arrived know what I was I
knew that mrs. Kim doesn't speak very
good English so I knew that I would
probably be speaking to her in Korea
right but then she said waited wait a
minute editor he's going to interview
you
20 minutes great I felt you know you
have that feeling as if your feet aren't
touching the ground
Wow look at me because up until now I've
stumbled you know whether I talked to
two other people I get all the endings
wrong and the reality is that you never
do as badly as you think and when I'm
talking to someone say a lesson on skype
I kind of feel it's important that I get
it right what I'm talking to this person
where I'm being interviewed all that
matters is that I get my meaning
so I can mangle the enemies it doesn't
matter I can tell by the way Eve not in
his head that he understood what I have
to say yeah that's all about yeah so
once you kind of remove this fear of
getting this wrong have I got it right
is this the right word just you have to
communicate because he's interviewing me
so I understood what he was saying most
of the time and and he seemed to
understand what I would say now but wait
the article that comes out of this but I
guess hardly to your kind of it's not
artificial that's real like this guy's
or actually this is a meaningful real
conversation as opposed to either even
just a lesson like with a tutor or
talking to the guy at the dry cleaners
which is always examples well and and
it's easier for me to talk about things
that I'm familiar with that's cleaning
how I got the stain on my sweater the
dry cleaner is very difficult yeah but
this just sometimes you're lucky to the
the nature of the questions right it
seems to be steered towards there it is
where you can use the words that you
have so that was good then I spoke with
mrs. Kim for quite a while and and all
of it was in Korean and that was
certainly it's like gee all my work has
been worthwhile I also think that
obviously the you know the listening and
the reading all of that is cumulative
and you're not aware of how much you're
improving you're not aware of every time
you're reading and listening the brain
is becoming just a little bit more
familiar with the words and the writing
system and the structure of the language
it just it just it's cumulative so you
just have to stay with it you have to
stay with it the brain gradually absorbs
it even if we don't think it does so
that was kind of neat so you had
probably what an hour I was there for an
hour yeah solid hours of Korean speaking
practice pretty well brain fatigue after
no you walk away not fifty you walk away
you know quite stimulating I can't wait
to get home because the other thing
I did this video yesterday about
discovering a Kim Yong Hwa's podcast
someone was kind enough to mention on my
youtube channel he's in fact a very
famous Korean writer and that he did a
TED talk and so I went to the website
and sure enough here is his TED talk
with transcript with translation so I
immediately alerted one of our outsource
people who helps us upload stuff to the
websites that please get this into the
Korean library and he sent me an email
it's up so as soon as I get home do that
20 minute discussion and it's an
interesting discussion about about you
know being more creative and a lot of
words that I know so today's a good day
no you walk out of there you did well
not here
fire got fired up you're not there's no
brain fatigue here absolutely every time
you have a victory that's why I think
it's so important for people to give
themselves credit for their little
victories because it's it just I think
it sends a electrochemical charge of
your brain you know the brain is keen to
learn again yeah where is it for always
it's easy enough to be frustrated about
the things we can't do because it's lots
of them yeah so you have to you know
take advantage of little victories in
yourself yeah during that conversation
did you know just some things some
issues that you should work on better in
the future really I'm more conscious of
those kinds of things when I'm having my
discussion with my tutor because I'm
more conscious of the fact that I'm
angling some in
because in Korean is the trouble Korean
is the word orders like Japanese and my
brain starts me down to Japanese but in
the end it's different from Japanese and
so that's it's hard to break that but
the brain thinks it's Japanese but it's
not it's great so in this I was so
focused on actually communicating on the
content that I actually I did better but
I think though subconsciously I will I'm
always focusing on those things word I
know I have difficulty when I listen
when I read yeah I was less conscious of
those kinds of problems than when I
speak when I when I studied Japanese
universe it was the same thing where my
Korean was already better at that point
that my Japanese and I found it very
difficult learning them simultaneously
switching back and forth because some of
the words are so similar they sound the
same
and so for me that was really difficult
not having an advanced level in Korean
and then starting fresh in life but
having the kind of closer and level that
definitely there's like confusion in my
great well it's a bit like the problem
with Russian and Czech Russian Czech
structurally are almost the same which
is not the case with Korean and Japanese
the problem in Russian with Russian
Czech is the vocabulary and you end up
not knowing is this a Russian word or a
Czech word because for half of them it
doesn't matter because they're more or
less the same but the other half are
completely different so if you use this
Russian word when you're speaking Czech
you know or vice versa yeah but with
Korean it's it's structurally it's the
ending of the verb that's going to tell
you the although because if whatever but
it works differently
okay that's our story for today